now many lawmakers across Capitol Hill
are praising the president's measured
response for example Senator Lindsey
Graham tweeted quote I appreciate
president Trump's desire to be measured
and thoughtful when it comes to Iranian
provocations before adding that nuclear
enrichment should be a redline joining
me now for a reaction our Republican
congressman Matt gates of Florida Mike
Turner from Ohio and Mike waltz who is
also from Florida gentlemen thank you so
much for joining in full disclosure I
served with the least two of the three
of you in the Congress and I want to get
your perspective and Congressman Turner
I want to start with you your your your
vantage point on the Intelligence
Committee I think is also a very
important one in addition to Armed
Services there is a very important date
that's coming up which is July 8th which
is the deadline that Iran has put out
they picked the number there for Europe
to help get out of these Iranian these
sanctions that are crippling their
economy give us your perspective on
what's happening in Iran and the
pressure that they're now feeling from
the economic sanctions well secretary
Pompeo has described his maximum
pressure campaign which of course is to
try to bring Iran back to the table to
renegotiate the jcpoa the nuclear deal
that the this administration stepped out
of obviously the goal here is to ensure
that we do not have a nuclear Iran Iran
is feeling the pressure of those
sanctions our European allies who are in
that deal with us are feeling also the
pressure and understanding that this
this deal needs to be negotiated now
some claim that Iran's reaction to that
obviously the tanker attacks that which
they're being blamed and perhaps even
this drone attack what's interesting at
Capitol Hill is the debate is trying to
restrict the president's actions at a
time where the president is actually
showing restraint so this is certainly I
think an interesting debate that's
happening in Congress watching the
president as the Democrats claim he's
trying to take us to war he's showing
restraint and trying to take us to the
bargaining table now congressman walz
you're a freshman there your first term
in Congress but your military service
gives you an interesting perspective
following up on what congressman Turner
was talking about what is the atmosphere
what are Democrats and Republicans alike
talking about on Capitol Hill what are
their worries and concerns but Jason
I've operated against
the Iranians on the ground and and and
dealt with them from previous service in
the White House and I can tell you the
underlying premise here is is what we
have to agree on and whether it's al
Qaeda in Afghanistan whether it's Isis
in Iraq whether it's its Iranian backed
terrorists all over the region we have
to fight these wars over there we have
to take care of it abroad and places
like Damascus and Tehran and Kabul or it
will follow us home this notion that we
see on both the right and the left that
if we just let them take care of it and
bring the troops home and the world will
be fine I think as naive we have seen
that it will follow us into Europe it
will follow us in the United States we
have to stay on offense and while I
absolutely respect the president's right
as commander-in-chief which all three of
us had fought for on the Armed Services
Committee his right to give these green
light
these go/no-go decisions we do have to
respond Iran as a regional bully it will
continue to push it is emboldened by
weakness and it is deterred by strength
and the president I fully support of him
keeping the maximum pressure campaign
going the reason they came to the table
for the Iran deal in the first place is
the sanctions were working and I think
he's made it very clear he's going to
drive them back to the table but get a
better deal in the long run and that's
absolutely what he needs to do now
congressman gates what are you hearing
and seeing from your colleagues on the
floor of the house what are their
reactions to it because not everybody
thinks like what congressman walz and in
turner just articulated yeah I have
great respect for my fellow Floridian
Michael Walt's he's an American patriot
but I think what's naive is believing
that engaging in endless unfocused
unconstitutional regime change wars in
the Middle East is effective either in
the Middle East or back home I mean you
just look at Afghanistan
we're down from having the Afghan
government cut your to controlling 72%
of their administrative districts to 56
percent of their administrative
districts in the last three years and
you look at the six trillion dollars
that we've spent in the region and you
think that's larger than the market cap
of Facebook Google and Amazon combined I
think an American first foreign policy
advanced by the president is one that
would prioritize getting the
Gulf Cartel out of the southwestern
united states before we decide that
we're going to be the policemen of the
gulf of oman and if you've got Japan and
Norway not seeking war for vessels owned
by folks in their countries being
attacked I don't think it's the job of
the United States to avenge foreign
vessels or American robots with the
blood of our bravest servicemembers and
Patriots Michael Walt's being one of
them now congressman Turner I don't
think you'd necessarily agree with
everything that congressman gates just
said would you well I think Jason that
you know when we have this debate we
have to understand that enemies
self-select and the most important thing
that we can do is have a strong military
and a president that's not restrained in
being able to take action the debate
unfortunately and that in the house over
the past two weeks as just this week the
Democrats voted to actually repeal the
2001 authorization of use of force that
was passed after 9/11 that allowed us to
go after al-qaeda and Isis and continue
to attack all those who want to do the
United States harm and just last week
there was debate about restricting the
president's ability to respond to Iran
that would have prevented the president
United States from responding even if
Iran attacked Israel we have to stand up
for allies we have to stand up for
ourselves recognize that that enemies
self-select and ensure we have a strong
military to respond to protect our
country congressman walz is the
president doing what he's supposed to be
doing here how would you assess what's
happened so far yeah well I think we're
all three of us absolutely agree is
maintaining options for the president
and not allowing the Democrats to tie
his hands for political reasons he is
the commander in chief he does get to
make those decisions Congress does have
a role in line with the War Powers Act
but but at the end of the day you know
in response to Mike my good friend
representative Gaetz at the end of the
day we have to fight this abroad I do
not want to fight this in the United
States and when half the world's
terrorist organizations exist in
Afghanistan when Isis is sending and
weaponizing refugees into Europe in the
United States and when Iran is openly
seeking to attack Israel and to build a
nuclear weapon to attack all of us it's
only the United States that can lead and
whenever we withdraw like Obama did
out of Iraq and like Obama tried to do
out of Afghanistan bad things happen if
we don't lead then we leave the world
open to China and Russia and Islamic
extremism America has to lead that does
not mean we have half a million troops
on the ground there is a lot of space
between kumbaya world peace and a
million soldiers on the ground and and
those are the options the Pentagon needs
to be presenting to the president right
now so congressman gates from your
perspective is Donald Trump the
president United States doing the right
thing or do you think he's taking a
misstep here along the way no the
president has been measured and mindful
and effective the message has been sent
to Iran that the only reason these
strikes didn't occur is that the
president wanted to make sure that we
gave peace a chance
president Trump understands that we get
peace through strength but we can also
achieve strength through restraints and
I just I don't get it I mean the Middle
East represents 3.5 percent of global
GDP and we are obsessed with this area
of the world meanwhile China represents
15 percent of global GDP and they have
expanded their empire without firing a
single shot while we've been involved in
these endless Middle Eastern wars I
think we do need to reform the 2001
authorization to use military force
because if brave Patriots are willing to
go fight and die in these wars I think
members of Congress ought to have the
guts to vote forum or against them and
to make sure that we follow the
Constitution in the application of
military force but the president well
has shown that he's mindful and
effective well the debate will continue
but I think it's naive to say that China
has never fired a shot all you need to
do is go visit with Vietnamese and
others as I've done when I was in
Congress in this year's but - yeah well
it probably in the last 12 months - with
all due respect I think if you looked
harder at what the Chinese are doing
it's a very aggressive thing they're not
engaged in an endless for the world they
are they are they are
gentlemen for the other day I really do
think that the right answer to this is
if the provoked that president itíd
states has clear authority if there's
clear and present danger to take
whatever actually needs to if he's going
to take a long time war then he should
go to Congress and he should get that
authorization but that's my perspective
who left to debate this more gentleman
thank you for your service thanks for
joining us here on this Hannity special